This is analytics for a
one-month-old website
that we
created
live on this YouTube
channel.  He already has
over 150 active
users on the
site.  We receive
visitors from the
United States,
Canada, Germany, and the
United Kingdom.
So, this is very high-quality
traffic.  The pages are
getting views,
and it is growing
month after month.  This is
data from Google Search Console.  We
see that the site
is getting a few
clicks and impressions.  It
ranks for
targeted queries,
pages are taking
positions, and we are once again
seeing
visitors from
top countries.  This is the
second website
we also created
live on
this YouTube channel
just 10 days ago.  As
you can see, it was
indexed on
August 9th.  It is
August 18th.  So, we
see that this site,
which is less than 14
days old, or about two
weeks old, already has over
72 pages
indexed in Google.
It is indexed,
and we can see from
queries that it is already
ranking for its
target
keyword.  This is a website
about tours to Niagara, and
we see that it is already
ranking for these
queries.  So if you
want to build a
website for yourself or a
client,
get results quickly,
and take all
the guesswork out of SEO and
development, I
highly
recommend
continuing to watch
this video.  We
used my
Ranksite tool to
create both of these
websites.  So, the
first site was Core
Grid.  This is a site that is
just over a month old
and is already showing
great results.  We
see that this is a
full-fledged website.
All
our services are presented here.  Each
section
contains
individual
images when clicked.  Everything has
internal links.
Everything includes
service areas,
FAQs,
and unique
content on each of
these pages.  If we
take a look at Ranksite, you
will understand why it
works so well.
If we move on to the
SEO and GEO sections, we
will see that all the
technical aspects of
creating a site are already
taken into account when
using Ranksite.
Everything is here: robots.txt, LLMs.txt,
AI, JSON, sitemap and LLM are
also present.  So,
everything necessary from a
technical point of view is
already there.  All you
need to do
when creating a website
is to go to
create a new
project.  I just
need to enter
information about my
business, what it
does, and
who it
serves, and
add my logo.
And then my website
will be built with
technical SEO and
optimization in mind from the
start.  So, we
see this is your
checklist.
We also have an SEO checklist that
we can
go through.  If I
open any of
these pages, let's take
a look.  We
will go to any
of these pages.
We will move on to
editing.  We
see that all of these
pages also have a
scheme for local
businesses.  So the schema
was updated for
each of these pages
.  This lets Google
know exactly what these
pages are about.  And I believe that
when you make
Google's life easier, that's why
we get such
incredible
results from these
sites.  Again,
this site, Best Nagra Touris, I'll
leave a link to the
video in the description.  We
created this website
about 10 days ago, and
it is already ranking and
showing good
results.  So
again, if I
go back to Ranksite, we
see here our schema
, our images,
title, meta description,
and we can also
manually index
any page.
So, if I click "
index this
page," it will be
submitted to
Google's indexing queue.  If
I go to
settings and then
to
search engine indexing
, like this.  We can
go and see the
status of these pages.
So we can see
if they are
indexed or
have been submitted for
indexing.  We
can also manually
submit all these
pages to Google to
increase
the likelihood that
it will index our
content and it will
appear in search.
So instead of
waiting 6-7 months
for your content
to appear in Google, as you
can see,
by using a
tool like RankSite, which
is designed to
help with
ranking, you
can achieve
results much
faster.  So, that was
our Core Grid website.  As
you can see, you can
create pages,
everything you need is here.
If you go to
my site, it will tell you
exactly what to
create.  So if
you need to
generate more
service pages or
location pages, you
can simply
create them.  It will already
tell you what to
do, so
you don't have to
guess anything
yourself.  You
can also set up a
blog automation process where you can
find
post ideas and generate
new posts.  So this is
for Core Grid, and as I
told you, we created
another site—bestniagra.com.
So, again,
if I go over and
click on best nagrators.com, we
see that this is a new
website here.  And again
we can go and
click on
any of them.  We
will see the image.
We will see the
actual content.
Everything is unique.  This is all
HTML too.  Everything
is ranking quickly.  And it has
very, very good
page speed insights.
If we check
both of these websites,
we will see that they
have very good
page speed insights.
So, again, I
can go to, um, I
can index
any of these
pages if I want to
.  If we go to
edit, we
can see that
even for our
blog post.
Let's move on to
editing our
blog post.  It
has our type of
blog post layout.
Our JSON LD schema is also
already added.  So,
again, an
amazing
tool that you
can
use to
create SEO-
optimized
websites for yourself or
your clients.  We
also now
support
partner products
.  You can add
your own
affiliate product here
, and it will
appear naturally throughout
your website.
If we move on to
apps, we also have an
app marketplace
that we continue
to develop.  You can
add your
cookie consent banner.  You can add a
chatbot like this to
your website.  Then
your website will have a
full-fledged, er,
chatbot that is trained
on your
website's information.  And you
can also add some
new things like a
heatmap and
visitor analytics widget.  And again
, we
will continue to
add more and
more apps
completely
free of charge.
We currently have a lifetime
offer for rank site.
So if you want to
take advantage of this, you
can, um, go to the
pricing update section.  And as you can see, if
you use the
link below, you'll
get a $70 discount
on each plan.  So,
you can get a
$70 discount on
any plan you
choose here.  And this is
extremely valuable
because you
get hosting
absolutely
free.  All
you pay for is
essentially, um, space for a
website, and you can
customize the website
however you
like.  and then,
um, hosting is included.
So, if you want to
take advantage of this
offer, just
click on the
link below.
I hope you
guys enjoyed
this video.  If so,
let us know
by giving us a
big like.  And if
you have any other
questions, let me
know in the comments
below.  Thank you and
goodbye.